much other states are worried about the
coronavirus straining their hospital
systems more than 8,000 people in
Florida alone are now hospitalized with
the virus and our lead national
correspondent David Beck now is
following all this from Tampa for us
David good morning what if anything our
Florida Hospital is doing to treat more
patients so look the governor has said
it's not an issue of having enough
hospital beds it's a matter of having
enough people to treat the patients so
we just found out that the governor has
secured three thousand nurses from
elsewhere other states to come here to
Florida about 100 we're told are coming
to Tampa we came to Tampa because this
is the largest hospital in this area we
wanted to check on how things were going
and we spoke to one of the leaders in
the emergency department who said listen
we have seven ICU beds available it
doesn't sound good but we're doing
everything we can to ride that wave
right now and not get overwhelmed by the
patients who keep coming in day after
day if you have wave after wave after
wave how long can you sustain that that
is dr. Jason Wilson he's the associate
director of emergency management at
Tampa General Hospital
he says the volume of Kovac patients
coming to the hospital is five times
higher than it was a month and a half
ago we've really done everything we can
to try to keep pace on the hospital they
don't need to be in the hospital the
situation is far more dire in South
Florida there are now just 10 ICU beds
left in all of miami-dade County the
most populated county in the state we
were seeing in wuhan six months ago five
months ago now we are there dr. Lillian
Abu is chief of infection prevention for
Jackson Health System
she says doctors and nurses and her
hospitals are working around the clock
due to the sheer volume of patients and
some of them are getting sick because on
a normal basis without Karuna bars
there's already a nursing shortage
that's Melissa she's a nurse from
Florida who went to New York City at the
height of that city's outbreak
she says she's petrified with crisis in
several states now that there won't be
enough nurses like her to come down to
Florida to help
right now Texas is sucking in all ICU ER
nurses they're getting all the specialty
nurses Arizona is getting the leftovers
of that so what is Florida that that's
what's really scary about this in
addition to a need for more testing
there is an extraordinary need we're
told for convalescent plasma
convalescent plasma comes from people
who survived the corona virus and have
the antibodies in their blood we heard
from one blood second-largest blood bank
in the country the largest in the state
of Florida and right now what they said
is doctors are using convalescent plasma
earlier on in the treatment process
because it's proving to be more
beneficial they're not just using it on
the sickest patients so there's more of
a need because there are more patients
so if you have recovered
you can donate every 28 days and they
desperately need that plasma from you
Anthony
everything helps David